- [Voiceover] This episode
of CC: Social Scene
is based on your
suggestions on how to take
the perfect profile picture.
- [Voiceover] These are
all dumb and terrible,
- I know, we need to get
some good profile pictures.
(camera snapping)
- Ugh, I'm never
gonna figure this out.
- What up?
- Who are you?
- I'm Selfie Self, this
is my girl Photo Bomb,
and we 'bout to teach you
how to take the perfect
profile picture.
(snappy music)
♪ How to make the
perfect profile picture
♪ Lights, focus, you
need the perfect mixture
♪ How to make the
perfect profile picture
♪ Get it right, yo, it's tight,
all the likes, it'll get ya
♪ Step one, quality is job one
♪ If your profile pic is
blurry, it be seen by no one
♪ Step two, step two,
here's what you got to do
♪ Use a angle, no dangles,
and it always looks cool
♪ Step three, don't be creepy
♪ Half-naked in the
bathroom clickin' selfies
♪ Step four, four, here's
the coffin to the nail
♪ Add a cat to the picture,
meow, it never fails
♪ That's a tight
cat, it never fails
♪ How to make the
perfect profile picture
♪ Lights, focus, you
need the perfect mixture
♪ How to make the
perfect profile picture
♪ Get it right, yo, it's tight,
all the likes, it'll get ya
♪ Be boring or sad, that's whack
♪ Be fun, take a picture
by your giant pancake stack
♪ If you ugly, but
you wanna be a hottie
♪ Just Photoshop your
head on a better body
♪ Get that Photoshop,
that's hot, that's hot
♪ Now you good, it
looks like it should
♪ Put on as many filters as
you could, all the filters
♪ One mo tip, no
matter time and place
♪ Never take a profile
picture with a duck face
♪ Quack quack, don't do
it, quacky quack quack
♪ How to make a
perfect profile picture
♪ Lights, focus, you
need the perfect mixture
♪ That's how to make the
perfect profile picture
♪ Get it right, yo, it's tight,
all the likes, it'll get ya
♪ All the likes, all the likes
♪ All the likes,
all the likes, yeah
♪ All the likes, all the likes
- Aw, yeah, thanks guys.
- My profile picture
looks so cool.
- Tight, we gonna go
back in the closet now.
- Bye, y'all.
- See ya.
(doors shutting)
Do you think they live in there?
- If they do, they
should pay rent.
- Right.
- We ain't payin' rent.
- [Voiceover] Thanks for
watching CC Social Scene.
Be sure to check
out all our sketches
on Comedy Central's
YouTube channel,
presented by Redd's Apple
Ale, pick different.